THEY ARE FOCUSSING ON GETTING
THE BAR REOPENED.
>> Dana: TREY GOWDY A FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR.
I REMEMBER A WHILE AGO, YOU
TALKED ABOUT THE NEED FOR
RATIONALITY AND ALSO IN YOUR
BOOK, WHERE YOU WRITE TALKING
ABOUT PERSUASION, RATIONALITY
COMES TO MIND.
LISTEN TO ADMIRAL GERRARD THIS
MORNING TALKING ABOUT THESE
RULES.
>> WHAT BREAKS MY HEART I DON’T
KNOW OF ANY DATA THAT SAYS YOU
NEED TO SHUT DOWN OUTDOOR DINING
AND OUTDOOR BARS.
WE NEED TO DO WHAT IS NECESSARY
TO TURN THE PANDEMIC BUT NOT
MORE.
THAT IS NOT EVIDENCED BASED.
>> Dana: IS THAT RATIONAL?
>> YOU PUT YOUR FINGER ON THE
RIGHT WORD.
AMERICANS FOR TWO CENTURIES HAVE
PROVEN THEY ARE WILLING TO
SACRIFICE FOR THE BETTERMENT OF
OTHER PEOPLE BUT DOLLAR HAS TO
BE A RATIONAL CONNECTION BETWEEN
WHAT YOU ARE ASKED TO DO AND THE
DESIRED OUTCOME.
THAT’S WHAT FRUSTRATES PEOPLE.
WHEN YOU ARE JUST DOING IT
BECAUSE YOU HAVE THE POWER TO DO
IT AND THE OTHER THING IS THE
HYPOCRISY.
THE LEADERS DON’T FOLLOW THE
RULES THEY SET FOR OTHERS.
YOU THINK ABOUT THE
JURISDICTIONS WHERE YOU CAN
WATCH DESTINY IN A STRIP CLUB
BUT CAN’T SEE THE VIRGIN MARY ON
THE WALL OF YOUR CHURCH.
THERE HAS TO BE A RATIONALITY.
GOOD LEADERS ARE THE FIRST TO
PICK UP THE HEAVY TASK AND THE
LAST TO PUT IT DOWN.
THEY ARE NOT EATING IN FANCY
FRENCH RESTAURANTS IN CALIFORNIA
WHILE TELLING EVERYONE ELSE THEY
CAN’T DO IT.
>> Dana: THE OTHER THING I
THOUGHT YOU WOULD WANT TO
COMMENT ON.
WE SAID ON THIS PROGRAM, THE
NEED FOR SOME COVID RELIEF FOR
THE PEOPLE WHO REALLY NEED IT.
IT’S BEEN ON HOLD.
SPEAKER PELOSI TODAY REVEALED
HER HAND.
WATCH THIS.
>> THIS HAS SIMPLICITY.
IT’S WHAT WE’VE HAD IN OUR BILLS
FOR A SHORTER PERIOD OF TIME.
THAT’S OKAY NOW BECAUSE WE HAVE
A NEW PRESIDENT.
>> Dana: IT’S OKAY NOW BECAUSE
THERE IS A NEW PRESIDENT?
>> THAT’S ONE OF THE DUMBEST
THINGS I HAVE EVER HEARD
A LEADER SAY.
BECAUSE JOE BIDEN WON IT’S OKAY
TO DO IT.
IF DONALD TRUMP HAD WON -- WHEN
YOU ARE SUFFERING, IN ECONOMIC
SELF-DEFENSE MODE, YOU DON’T
CARE ABOUT POLITICS.
YOU WANT TO KEEP YOUR BUSINESS
GOING AND FAMILY FED.
YOU DON’T WANT TO BE EVICTED
FROM YOUR HOME.
THE NOTION BECAUSE HER TEAM WON
IN NOVEMBER SHE WILL DO
SOMETHING, WHAT IS MISSING IS IF
RAUL RYAN SAID WHAT SHE JUST
SAID THERE WOULD BE MEDIA
OUTCRY.
WHAT OTHER ENTITY HAS COMMENTED
ON WHAT THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
JUST SAID?
BECAUSE BIDEN WON, WE WILL DO
IT.
TRUMP, WE WERE NOT GOING TO GIVE
HIM A VICTORY.
IT’SO OUTRAGEOUS.
IT’S HARD TO GET ME UP SET BUT
WHAT SHE SAID MAKES ME MADDER
THAN HELL.
>> Dana: AND IT TAKES A WHILE TO
GET THE PAYMENTS PROCESSED.
THE FACT THEY MIGHT GET
SOMETHING DONE BEFORE CHRISTMAS
IS LOOKING AT ANOTHER 4 WEEKS